شيماء الابراهيمي مقيم في لندن وواحده من
بين اكثر من 37% من سكان بريطانيا ممن
يعانون من الوزن الزائد
على الرغم من زياده الوزن اللي عندي روت
لنا التجربه التي خاضتها مع عقار اوزنبيك
على امل ان يمنحها النتيجه المرجوه
السيلبرتي فاشن
تروحين على التيك توك والكل يتكلم فيه
تدخلين على السوشيال ميديا للكل يتكلم فيه
واحنا كنساء دائما نكون نحب بيرفكت ولهذا
سبب مرحله طول الوقت بس ان شاء الله يعني
على طول هذا الشيء احنا نحاول يعني
اني بالنسبه لي كانت تجربتي اريد اشوف
الدواء بيشتغل لو لا
ناس بتتاثر بالسوشيال ميديا يعني انا نفسي
لما اطلع بره وبيكون عندي جمعت صبايا
والبنات صاحباتي اول شيء بقولوا لي سمعت
عن هذا الدواء بينزل بيخسس ونزلت عليه شخص
فلانه 15 كيلو رغم نجاح العلاج بشكل كبير
لكن النتائج جاءت عكس توقعات شيماء قمت
بكون نايمه على الفراش وببكي وما بتحمل اي
احد بيتكلموا يا ايه اخذت اجازه من الشغل
قلت ما يبيها تاثير الحاله النفسيه من
الشغل ضغط الشغل علي بس
زادت الحاله قمت بنتبه كل ما باخذ الجرعه
الاسبوعيه بعدها بيومين بنتكس
بينما فشلت تجربه شيماء في انقاص وزنها
يتفاخر العديد من المؤثرين والمشاهير على
مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي بالنتائج فلمن
يصلح هذا الدواء
من ايلون ماسك الذي اشاد بالدواء في انقاص
وزنه على تويتر مرورا بعدد من السياسيين
كبرج جونسون الذي اعترف بفشل الدواء في
مساعدته
الى مجموعه من المؤثرين على مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي الذين شاركوا رحلتهم مع انقاص
الوزن
الكثير من المرضى الذين يعانون مشاكل
الوزن معرضون لخطر الاصابه بالعديد من
الامراض المرتبطه بالسمنه مثل السرطان
مثلا لذلك العقار يحاول تقليل هذا الخطر
اذا كان بامكان المرضى فعل ذلك من خلال
اتباع نظام غذائي وممارسه الرياضه فهذا
امر رائع ولكن مع لجوء العديد من الناس
ذوي الوزن الطبيعي الى هذه العقاقير كيف
يتعامل الطب مع هذه الموضه
ساشعر بالقلق اذا استخدم شخص بوزن طبيعي
تلك العقاقير لانه على الارجح لا ينجح ولا
توجد دراسات علميه بان العقار امن
للاستخدام في هذه الحاله ادويه تخسيس
الوزن ثاني اكثر الادويه قيمه بين شركات
الصيدله وبغض النظر اذا ما كان وصفها
مسموحا قانونيا من يريد جسما نحيفا يجد
طريقه للحصول على الدواء اما عوارضه
الجانبيه فالوقت كفيل بالاجابه عنها لصباح
العربيه من لندن عرب عبد الحق لمتابعه
المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات